>> Tucker: DEMOCRATS ARE FINDING
IT HARDER AND HARDER TO WIN THE
VOTES OF ORDINARY AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THEY HAVE A NEW STRATEGY.
CREATE A NEW BORDER POOL.
LET 16 YEARS OLD VOTE AND GIVE
THE VOTE TO VIOLENT CRIMINALS
BEHIND BARS.
BERNIE SANDERS ARGUED THOSE WHO
BREAK THE LAWS SHOULD STILL BE
ABLE TO VOTE TO MAKE THEM.
>> YOU THINK INCARCERATED PEOPLE
SHOULD VOTE?
WOULD YOU COMMIT TO THAT?
>> THAT'S THE DIRECTION WE
SHOULD GO.
>> Tucker: LET INCARCERATED
PEOPLE VOTE.
PRISONS ARE VOTED IN RURAL
AREAS.
INMATES COULD RUN THE TOWN THAT
HOLDS THEM BECAUSE THEY WOULD BE
THE BIGGEST VOTING BLOCK.
MARK STEIN JOINS US.
THE INMATES NOT JUST RUNNING THE
ASYLUM BUT THE TOWN?
>> YES, THE THING TO REMEMBER
ABOUT BERNIE SANDERS, HE IS
ACTUALLY THE FRONTRUNNER.
TO CONTINUE WITH YOUR ASYLUM
ANALOGY, IN THE LAND OF THE
ENTIRELY DERANGED, THE FITFULLY
SANE MAN IS KING.
BERNIE SANDERS, JUST 10 MINUTES
AGO YOU MENTIONED A BURST OF
SANITY ON IMMIGRATION.
HE SAID WE CAN'T HAVE OPEN
BORDERS BECAUSE ALL OF THE
WORLD'S POORS WILL WANT TO COME
HERE.
HE SOUNDED AS CRAZY AS YOU.
BERNIE SANDERS OR TUCKER
CARLSON?
THEN HE BOWS TO THE BASE OF THE
PARTY.
HE IS SHREWDER THAN KAMALA
HARRIS AND CORY BOOKER AND THE
REST OF THEM.
IF HE DOESN'T BLOW IT LIKE HE
DID LAST TIME, HE WILL BOD
DID LAST TIME, HE WILL BED
DID LAST TIME, HE WILL BE THE
SANE GUY.
>> Tucker: WHY COULDN'T YOU HAVE
A CANDIDATE WHO WAS POPULACE ON
ECONOMICS BUT MORE CONSERVATIVE
ON THE SOCIAL ISSUES?
FOCUSSED ON THE COUNTRY RATHER
THAN THE REST OF THE WORLD AND
PRO-FAMILY.
THOSE ARE NOT INCOMPATIBLE
POSITIONS ARE?
>> THAT'S WHERE THE SWEET SPOT
IN POLITICS IT.
10 YEARS AGO WE HAD WHITMAN AND
PATAKI HE WAS FISTICALLY
CONSERVATIVE AND SOCIALLY
LIBERAL.
THE SWEET SPOT IS THE OPPOSITE.
THAT'S WHERE OLD SCHOOL
SOCIALISTS LIKE BERNIE SANDERS
WOULD HAVE BEEN QUITE
COMFORTABLE BEING.
BERNIE SANDERS'S BROTHER IS LIKE
AN OLD-SCHOOL BRITISH LABOR
PARTY SALT.
-- SOCIALIST.
HE IS ALL ABOUT THE VILLAGE
WORKERS.
NOT THE 6.5 BILLION OTHER
WORKERS THAT WANT TO MOVE HERE
ONCE YOU OPEN THE BORDERS.
THAT'S THE SWEET SPOT.
>> Tucker: I DON'T THINK THEY
ARE SMART ENOUGH TO DO THAT.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ START
SPORTING A NEW ACCENT WHILE
SPEAKING AT SHARPTON'S
CONFERENCE.
>> THIS IS WHAT ORGANIZING LOOKS
LIKE.
THIS IS WHAT BUILDING POWER
LOOKS LIKE.
I AM PROUD TO BE A BARTENDER.
AIN'T NOTHING WRONG WITH THAT.
>> Tucker: ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ SAID SHE IS FROM
THE BRONX AND ALWAYS SPOKEN THAT
WAY.
SHE SAID THAT HER NORMAL VOICE
IS THE FAKE ONE.
NOT THE FIRST DEMOCRAT TO DO
THIS.
>> I DON'T FEEL NO WAYS TIRED.
I COME TOO FAR FROM WHERE I
STARTED FROM.
NOBODY TOLD ME THAT THE ROAD
WOULD BE EASY.
>> Tucker: MARK, IF YOU
PATRONNIZE AN AUDIENCE THAT
MUCH, WOULD YOU FEEL SHAME?
>> WELL, IN FAIRNESS, I WOULD
SAY ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ --
HILLARY CLINTON IS TERRIBLE AT
IT.
ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE.
I SPEAK AS A FOREIGNER.
I CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
AND WILLIAM F.BUCKLEY JUNIOR.
ALL OF YOU AMERICANS SOUND THE
SAME TO ME.
HILLARY CLINTON CAN'T DO IT.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ TO GET
AWAY WITH IT IN A WAY THAT
HILLARY CLINTON CAN'T.
I THINK FOR HILLARY CLINTON AND
JOE BIDEN, THEY HAVE TO PUT
Y'ALL BACK IN.
THOSE PEOPLE ARE SAYING I WANT
TO BE SOMETHING OTHER THAN
WHITE.
TAKE MY WHITENESS AWAY FROM ME.
I AM INDIAN LIKE ELIZABETH
WARREN.
I AM HISPANIC LIKE BETO O'ROURKE
OR JUST WHOEVER I AM STANDING IN
FRONT OF LIKE HILLARY.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
WHATEVER YOU SAY ABOUT HER IS
DOING IT WITH A MUCH LIGHTER
TOUCH.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A FAIR POINT.
WE ARE ROUGHLY THE SAME AGE.
DIDN'T YOU GROW UP IN A WORLD
WHERE PEOPLE WERE ENCOURAGED TO
BE WHO YOU ARE NATURALLY ARE.
COULD YOU LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE PEOPLE ARE ASHAMED OF WHAT
THEY ARE?
THAT'S THE OPPOSITE WHAT HAVE WE
WANT.
>> I LIVED THROUGH A WHOLE
GENERATION OF STUPID SONGS ABOUT
BEING AUTHENTIC.
LEARNING TO LOVE YOURSELF IS THE
GREATEST LOVE OF ALL.
I GOTTA BE ME.
ALL OF A SUDDEN WE HAVE
POLITICIANS WHO ARE TRYING TO
PRETEND -- ELIZABETH WARREN IS
HARVARD'S LAW SCHOOL FIRST WOMAN
OF COLOR AND NOBODY LAUGHS.
THAT'S THE FIRST INSANITY.
WE LAUGH AT IT.
BUT EVERYONE WHO MATTERS IN
AMERICA TAKES THAT NONSENSE
SERIOUSLY.
>> Tucker: IS IT SUSTAINABLE TO
TELL PEOPLE THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF HOW THEY WERE BORN?
>> NO, I THINK IT'S UNHEALTHY.
THAT'S WHAT IS INTERESTING.
FOR ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ,
SHE IS A YOUNG WOMAN AND LIKE
SHE IS GOOFING AROUND WITH THAT
CROWD.
FOR HILLARY, IT SAYS SOMETHING
APPALLING ABOUT OUR POLITICAL
CLASS.
THEY CAN BE FRONT OF US FOR 4
DECADES AND NOT KNOW WHO THEY
ARE.